let's try to find the LCM of 30 and 20
using the prime factorization method as
the name says we need to reduce the
number to its prime factors 30 can be
written as 2 * 3 * 5 and 20 can be
written as 2 * 2 * 5 to find the hcf we
just took the factors that are common to
both the numbers and then mul multiplied
them but while finding the LCM it is
always better to write the factors in
exponential form since there are two
twos here we can write this as 2^ 2
multiplied 5 to find the LCM we have to
multiply the highest powers of each
factor there are three factors to be
considered here 2 3 and five let's write
the LCM here the first factor is 2 and
2^ S is higher than two so we write a 2^
squar here the next factor is three did
you notice three exists in 30 but not in
20 so we just write down this three here
remember for LCM the factors need not be
shared we have to consider all factors
shared or not here's one way in which
you can look at it we can also multiply
this with 3 ra to 0 because it is 1 and
amongst 3 raed to 0 and 3 ra to 1 3 ra
to 1 is greater so we write a three here
and the last factor is five we have a 5
ra to 1 here as well as here as both
have the same power we write it as
is this is 4 * 3 * 5 which equals
60 you should note that we are
considering the highest power of each
factor whether it is shed or not we will
find the LCM of 12 and 16 using this
same
[Music]
technique